hi I'm Diane damn my project at the
whole festival this week this year is
pasa here's a short documentary and my
website is www Kanye
so tell us about salsa classes film
about a young boy who live deep in the
jungle of Burma at the age of 13 he
walks out of this village
to return some day to remedy whose
people situations both feminine and
dying of disease and that's just what
he's done 15 years later
I'm curious what advice can you give to
female filmmakers it's typically been a
man's game what advice can you give to
female filmmakers so that they can be
known and appreciated and not sort of
drown in some misconceptions whatever
you want to call it I mean I'm of the
opinion that if you are a filmmaker
whether you are a male or female it
takes a certain amount of courage and an
incredible amount of determination and I
think that in searching for stories to
tell in my opinion film is a perfect
medium to tell stories that matter and
consequently that's why I decided to
document such as life I feel it's a
story that matters and that what you
also do is you generate a window into a
world that people don't often get the
chance to see and I believe that that's
what filmmaking
giving me the opportunity to do so
female or not just persist if it's what
you have to do and it's what you love to
do and that's just what he do what's the
best way to command respect on the set
well again I've never had a problem
because on females
but I think that male or female again
it's the way the best command respect
anywhere is if you have a certainty of
your vision and you are sufficiently
confident invoke your talents and your
story then everyone rallies around that
I have been very fortunate in every film
that I've ever made that Mike who
recognizes that one I want to tell this
story and and two I know what I'm doing
what I want to talk about it all right
and so they respect that and they are
extremely helpful because I'm not I
don't know everything I don't know how
to do everything technically but I make
sure that the people involved in a
project can help me where I don't know
all the answers and I find that what
they do is they are more than generous
with their time and their
story that I hear that's great and
lastly what's the best advice for hiring
someone if you can be part of your team
they're going to essentially be a family
with you for a short time while you
finish the project what do you look for
aside from the skill set well the skill
set matters but I also look for someone
and I know it's been said many a time
you know it seemed player a collaborator
somebody who places the project and the
importance of getting a shot in the
importance of getting the story told
before ego and for self-interest and and
recognizing that there is a magic to
creating something compelling and all of
us to learn involved as I said in the
film I've been lucky enough to have
people involved in the films that I do
may get very caught up in the story were
telling and all they want to do is tell
that story of the best production value
and then there's just something really
it's there is no other experience like
it than to be in on a film shoot with
everybody you know behaving for those
are driving where the same professor
wonderful thank you